taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds hey taste
buddies it's the taste buds podcast i'm
joe derosa
sal volcano
what's up with you today dude
no nothing's over man i'm coming in i'm
going to come in hot on this one what's
up coming in hot no way no cc that's the
energy i'm getting right no not even no
you're in your head
i swear i'm not in my head i know when
i'm in my head are you upset you're just
upset because you're coming off an l
from a substitute last week
ah
listen we're going to talk about that in
a second
you took a big l
you couldn't even beat a novice this is
the first you couldn't even beat a
novice
and you lost a chocolate cake
should you be
considering your options now
should you be collecting unemployment
from the taste buds podcast i mean most
of chris's argument was in support of
chocolate cake yeah
yeah i mean we're going off i saw the
comments i don't even think chris really
even put up a fight no we we we we it
was it was a blind i'll tell you right
now cheesecake one on blind faith on the
pole
bees blown
bees are blown
i mean you had chocolate cake if i had
to pick the biggest powerhouses of all
time
it's like pizza
you know
i don't know
yeah pizza go ahead no i mean chocolate
cake is up there man
it's way out it's really like just
really up there it's way up there you
know what i think hurt me cheesecake
factory i think people
have really you were dealing with a
generation of people that have grown up
now with cheesecake like the factories
where they just well they make
cheesecakes in factories no the
restaurant sal
would be the cheesecake factory
the restaurant cheesecake factory
the restaurant cheesecake factory are
you being funny right now are you being
serious
i'm not what do you mean am i being
funny
what do you mean am i being funny
you chocolate cake versus cheesecake i'm
saying you know what i think hurt my
argument on the poll the fact that that
what
we're dealing with a generation of
people now that have lived their whole
lives with the cheesecake factory when i
was a kid that didn't exist in their
town i'm saying they just had factories
that's like a mcdonald's
but they just pump out cheesecakes they
gonna like just pump them out what is
this bit you're doing
it's not that good of a
i [ __ ] you were serious it was a good
bit when you were like are you serious
but then when you just kept doing it i
knew you weren't sure i tried to commit
yeah why did that happen you believe me
i stayed true to the con and then you
you hung in there good you hung in there
good you stopped believing you were the
opposite of journey you stopped
believing and by the way these are the
first smiles i've seen out of you all
day which is why i'm saying what's going
on with you today don't project you on
i'm not i'm in a good mood today you
came downstairs
uh when i arrived it's kind of
straight-faced
and they got a lot banging around with
you
we had a real serious it was an almost
somber merch conversation we had i would
say
[Laughter]
a merch memorial yeah
there was zero joy in that
then we were talking about somebody
famous whose names we will not name
and sal was going
we heard that this guy might be a jerk
and sal was going why is he a jerk and i
started going i called this two years
ago i've been telling you for two years
this guy's a jerk and not a smirk not a
you did buddy you did maybe a little
excitement like you know what you just
yeah because you can't claim
that you called this person a jerk
because you have left a wake of jerk
calling and
you you call everyone a jerk it's almost
never wrong
so you can't hit one and be like called
it yeah but i mean just the last out of
your buddy like no i know but i i i
forgot that you called that that hurts
even more
i can remember the top line people you
think are jerks i don't know if he was
yeah you know what now you mentioned it
you did you did take a stand against a
whole trip
yeah yeah and we heard a story that
might confirm that yes but i i i didn't
want to immediately go to besmirch i got
you i got you but it was the second time
in this very room a two-year call on my
part took place what was that warfare i
can't say the name oh wow
i can't see the name okay but it's the
second time in two in in in six months
that you're that you're labeling of
someone as energy
that was argued by you who was confirmed
by the great pimp really yes i wish i
even knew who we were talking about
that's the second time it happened now i
have a question for you should should
the result of the last episode not count
the episode with chris or should we let
the fans decide absolutely should not
count i think we let the fans decide
okay i'm i'm fine with that i am i see
your point let me let me make this clear
i see a point and i haven't settled on
what i think yet because i don't
honestly if you won
i could be saying the same thing about
my record i wasn't there i think it's
fair he gets a sub
that's true well here's the thing though
i get to have a substitute you get to
pick a sub yeah but wait a second
there's a lot more to it than just a sub
we got to remember here cheesecake one
on blind faith of the pole okay so
myself get blind faith every week i know
i know but i'm saying though my sub you
can't you can't so if i took cheesecake
would have been this no i'm saying you
better give my sub the upper hand food
then
well going into that didn't we all
believe that chocolate cake was the
upper hand food i i thought it was going
to be a close heat i did not think i
would have chocolate cake would have
lost by the margin that it did lose what
was the finals there uh i have to
recheck it but it was it was a decent
loss
or something no no no what's up that was
an episode where you guys never said the
score so i didn't remember what coffee
versus t's percentage was but we said
who won or who lost
and you you didn't you demolish
me
babe i got bad news for you even if we
count the cheesecake win on your part
i'm beating you in two out of three
tiers
there's only one tier no it's not record
isn't it no there's the record tier
there's the percentage tier yeah but
that's because someone made a charge
here i'm way past margin i'm way past
you
babe
on this very show you pointed out how
important the margin difference was no
and you and you balked at it i said it
but it was in my favor
it was in my favor and you said i don't
give a [ __ ] wait you're telling you got
to do it like sports though a record i
mean and believe me there's a lot more
show left we're only separated by a win
or two i could totally take a loss still
but i'm saying like how do you go
then we have to right now
determine what is the meaningful
statistic what do you think pimp
i think just the overall wins just who
won how many matches
i i don't know i don't mind i don't mind
the disparity as well but then you need
a tiebreaker then you need a tiebreaker
well the tiebreaker is the third tier
that i'm also winning it
there are three tiers what's two out of
three good win
what's that what's the third time look
at the chart look at that wonderful
chart can we bring that chart up pimp
coffee won 65 35
coffee bt 65 to 35 after 34 000 votes no
no no at the end of the episode it was
not 65 35 at the end of the episode it
was like
62 48 or something like that but but 62
48
it was not that big of a margin at the
end of the uh when we oh so it was
closer than 65 30 yes that's what i'm
saying it was even closer yeah it was
not that bad i don't know because i
remember chris going that's huge and i
was like nah dude that's actually not
that big for this show
chris episode was actually 56-43
yeah so that's a big difference between
65-33 yeah that's close you can you
believe rice krispie treat versus
s'mores how did that end up
did you treat one
right now i have it at by one
percent because you never took the poll
down though no no it ends after a day oh
it does yeah 24 hours i keep them up
before i you've told me that many but
that one percent that is rematch oh no
that's where i took a that's where i
really got
margarita versus martini was 83-70 so at
the bottom of this
so so this is this is this isn't the
current thing pimp
uh i saw it on twitter we'll have to
find it but but the the wonderful fan
that that made the original
thing right
what's that called a spreadsheet
uh sh i believe was a she she keeps
updating she's updating it and she's
added yet another
category to it so it's three it's a
three-tier victory
hold on balance of the people no problem
but just because she's making
spreadsheets and and shooting them at
you on social media doesn't mean that
that's going to be the barometer by
which we choose who once wins i'm saying
she
this is my wife you're talking about
first of all
no she made a true statistical
spreadsheet
and i'm saying it contains three tiers
it contains percentage of wind win
majority percentage it contains total
wins and it contains there's a third
tier there
i can't speak to it right now joe
i can't even see any of that this is the
spreadsheet right all right yeah scroll
down
this shout out to this tip yeah that
lady sent me this see now this is saying
sal has no this is let's go to the glass
this isn't the up-to-date one oh yeah
it's not up to date i don't have the
link to that one i'm not sure where you
saw that i have the link to it here hold
on a second let me let me pull it up
right here
but while he's pulling that up i've so
pretty much what joe's saying
he gets one sub but it has to be an even
match up but i will make the case he was
there
and lost
right
so if he well i didn't lose i didn't
lose bad i lost 56.
i know i know i know sorry
sorry we get you know emotions run
higher out here hold on i'm looking for
the thing do i get his win
all right
how do you get a win when somebody
played the game for you that doesn't
because if i chose cheesecake in that
instance then that would have been the
vote if somebody subs in for tom brady
it still counts for the team that's
right by the way guess what tom brady
tom brady
if how about this how about this i was
the one doing the show that needed to be
done well uh king [ __ ] over here is off
on vacation how about that i was on the
bench and my team win i still get the
ring oh
you shut up
speaking of rings shout out uh tom brady
and the tampa bay bucks now this guy
became the oldest guy in the nfl he won
wins the super bowl at 43 years old
in tampa first year with tampa first
time it's ever synced up with a super
bowl is in the home team that's playing
stadium right shout out to him he's
doing amazing things you can't deny him
almost anymore but i would be remiss if
i didn't give a little shout
to patrick mahomes and okay the
organization that is the kansas city
chiefs because they're young they got
bright futures ahead and uh they're
really proven themselves so what's the
bit you're doing right now
i'm just letting you know that the the
super bowl just happened
and the super bowl happened correct tom
brady won with the tampa bay bank i
don't get the bit you're doing i'm
trying to find out
what's he doing he was 43 tom brady was
the oldest person in the nfl
is this is she is this him being like uh
he's tom brady what's the bit why are
you laughing so hard you're not getting
what i'm saying i don't get what you're
saying i'm shouting out tom brady and
the tampa bay bucks for winning the
super bowl okay
he won it as the oldest person playing
active in the nfl which is a feat in and
of itself he won it in his departure
from the patriots in his first year with
the bucks he won it when it just so
happened the super bowl was in tampa bay
these things all aligned to make quite a
footnote in history i'm giving him a
shout out but i would be remiss
if i didn't call out patrick mahomes and
the chiefs who had a stellar year who
had a championship under their belt a
year before who were young and bright
and certainly have a long career ahead
okay
that's all i'm doing no you're doing
something else i just don't understand
cause my my concentration is on my phone
so i can find this stupid chart i'm also
vamping
while you scroll social media i'm trying
to find a chart tom brady's the beer of
the nfl
he is he
what does that mean does that mean you
think beer is going to win i don't know
all right well let's diverse wine versus
one
joe is so into this question i can't
find this one you know it by clicking
what you don't know
is who has what and if you do know us
then you might be able to guess
uh i think they're no i actually think
they're gonna well actually give it
you're right yeah you might be able to
guess i i don't know who i would guess
who took what on this one in some cases
i would guess that you took wine in some
cases i would guess that i took wine i
would agree with you and i will say
enough you'll find this goddamn thing i
just wrote to the girl is this it here
okay is this the new one there you go oh
yeah also sal i i introduced the concept
of eating the fried tarantula as a
punishment to joe yeah and he said only
with the advice of a doctor
okay okay so i wouldn't do that
i would need i would need 70 was it 75
000. my total points are higher than
your total points
points
average is better than your average but
you have more wins than i do hold on
what does total points mean okay that's
percentage points
okay
so
you have won
by more higher percentage points so your
margin of victory on your wins is
greater than mine but i have won more
matchups i want you so how do you how do
you account for those two things
i would say it's three different tiers
but i just want you to take a look
at the top it doesn't make any sense six
landslide victories
who holds four of them
that's big oh are these in order of of
margin yes
no they're not yes they are no they're
not in order buddy
oh no they're in order of episode i'm
sorry right oh i'm sorry so those aren't
what you said those aren't the topics
okay six i do currently maintain pimp if
i'm not wrong though
and you can look at this a little better
than i could right now i contain the
majority of landslide victories
or the biggest landslide victory
but but
why would that matter right there's a
total points why does it matter if the
tampa bay bucks lose the game 50 to
nothing and win the next 15 games you're
defeating the one what does it matter
how bad the loss you're beating me it
ain't the game it's the player son
it's the player
you're dealing with jordan
you're dealing with jordan on the
wizards right now all right i'm confused
who's jordan on the wizards you're i'm
joined on the wizards as soon as i'm
jordan on the bulls you don't stand a
chance all right
i'm having trouble this is not tracking
all right you know who you are
you're rodman on the bulls
what does that mean team's carrying you
the team's carrying you
when it comes down to it and your was
yours were the wizards winning when
jordan was on no jordan couldn't carry
the whole team himself but he was the
best player on that team you better bet
your ass
and i get that you're a one-person team
and i get back onto what else would be
better than you when you when i get back
into a shop this is a great analogy
please continue because i i want to pick
it apart
please because i i think you're off the
rest
you i don't even understand
like again
like
so so so if we if we did if we did five
episodes right
and
i guess and i won four of the five 51 to
49 i understand and you won the fifth
one 99 to one you would win the season i
would have won in four right because you
have a better bigger margin i understand
by sports context by strict sports
contest i gave you just it's specific a
match context with only us hold on a
second i understand that if we look at
it as a sports season and we do it along
those lines okay that it's
wins is always the win right but that's
not all wins in life there are other
there are other competitive things where
a pers a higher percentage performance
percentage makes you the winner there
absolutely is stuff like that well hold
on a second okay sometimes like the way
that look at gymnastics for instance the
nature i'm lost i'm lost how are you
lost i am lost gymnastics is based on a
point percentage win that's how you win
it's point percentages
so are we doing
50 battles according to point
percentages my point is is if you looked
at this chart
as as a football season you won fine if
you looked at it as a gymnastics
competition i'm winning
that's what i'm saying
i don't understand what you don't get it
would you like to play this with jim
nastic's rules then i'd like to play it
with both and say and then add that
third tier and say you've got to win off
the third tier the third tier is the
average at the very bottom
what the f
what does the average matter it's your
average score my average score is higher
than your average score average matters
a lot
ever heard a learning curve ever heard
of how that affects the entire class let
me say a couple of things you you
completely completely skirted past my
perfect example to put your theory to
the test which is if we had five matches
and five matches only and i won four of
them by a margin of 51 to 49 and you won
one of them by a margin of 99 to one and
i was four and one but you had a higher
average and a bigger margin of victory
because that one lopsided victory would
you win with a one and four record
couldn't win one you couldn't win a
lopsided vic that you couldn't do that
for for it to be the laps the lopsided
victory to win on percentages it still
has to be a comparable heat
you couldn't there's i don't understand
how 199 to one would beat your four
other victories
because my margin of victory on the four
other ones were 51.49 so i won by a
percentage point each time so i won by
four total percent over four episodes i
see what you're saying you win by 90
margin of victory on your one win well
that's that's a very fair point but
that's not what we're dealing with here
it is
only what we're dealing with just for 35
episodes
it's the only thing where i just put it
down to five i mean it's funny
it's funny that she put
percentages and averages into the
scoreboard funny that you don't know who
she is it is she's dictating the terms
of this spot i mean she included it for
a reason this is the most professional
spreadsheet i've ever seen in my life i
don't deny it looks like a man
is it a man that did it ozzy oh i
thought it was a girl that did it
i think someone woman did the chart and
then someone else did the i don't know
god bless you whoever you are whoever
did it the point is this
those numbers are there for a reason joe
answer my pro my question though that in
that scenario would you say you would
win
at a one in four record because of one
lopsided victory no i'd say that's a
pretty good exception to the rule but
again but if you're going to be that is
exactly the scenario
it's not a bigger scale it's not exactly
the scenario because there is no 99
percent to one you know that you beat me
margarita to martini 83-17 because more
people like margaritas of course that's
why that's right and we're also doing a
year's work no gymnastics person wins
because they landed one
[Laughter]
figure skatings are better shaker
you don't just want to do
what is globally known as the
record-keeping for most professional
sports records
you want a diverse professional
freestyle we're not playing a
professional sport this is debate team
debate team there's categories of wins a
debate team doesn't win based on you won
you lost they went hold on keep in mind
they went on argument
facts knowledge information presentation
there that's why i'm saying statistical
evidence
matters but these are blind polls bro
it's just that we are hitching our wagon
we're betting the ponies is all we're
doing this is our betting record okay
you understand then
that's fine we're giving we're get we're
letting everyone take the journey with
us
while people don't know the results
we're swaying their opinions so that
when they get the results they firmly
planted maybe they didn't have a side
and then maybe our argument made them
say you know what i choose that side and
then the the
and then the popular voting is revealed
and then we all understand who was in
line and who wasn't in line all right
but you you understand the microcosm of
five episodes the theory behind it is
the scene when you expand it to 50
episodes i know that but you're using an
extreme extreme example i think i'm
using the most basic example no you what
you're using is is a scenario that would
never take place you would never have
four episodes where you won by one
percent and one episode where i won by
99 percent but that would never in a
million semantics of the argument the
same i'm just ill
i get it i get it show the relationship
to the entire chart it's still the same
i get it
but
i don't know if you do
i get it all i'm saying to you is is
there's a reason those percentages are
put in there at the bottom
they're only put in there because that's
the only information we feed the
audience there's those two number sets
no not those numbers not even but
there's a re if it was a matter of just
straight up wins to this audience it
would just say straight up wins there's
a reason there's better averages listed
at the bottom because we put percentages
i'm just saying sweetheart let me tell
you something right now i swear to god
you said that that was an important
number that's what's gonna be my next
sentence you're not letting me finish
all right go ahead
yeah i'm up by two two wins three if you
count chris and we're gonna leave it up
to the fans because i understand if i
wasn't there and i took let's say you
won then i could be like ah man i
wouldn't have counted it okay well that
that if that's the truth that's the
absolute truth then i i'm fine then i
fall i don't i don't think a show look
as you said it's yeah sure tom brady
gets the ring either way there's a team
there's a team of people playing okay
pete sampras can't skip the tennis match
and then somebody fills in for him that
this is tennis this is not football okay
yes that's a great point i no that's a
great point
what i said what you said what i said
i didn't say anything i'm saying you're
using a football analogy
okay you you are um a little off with
your sports analysis no i don't know if
you watched pete champers not play
tennis he he he i think he's a famous
tennis player he still plays okay
fine name any other famous tennis player
sure my point is this you made the point
earlier to defend you getting chris's
win as hey if tom brady's on the bench
he still gets the win in the ring
silly throw away okay but my point is
that's the the polls point is this so if
i was standing in that cheesecake we
never would have done that match up if
it was you my point is i did it because
chris loves cheesecake
this is fair if the fans vote that
account do you agree to the terms of you
don't agree we would have never so it's
not going up to fan vote we've hold on a
second let no i look i can have some say
in this right now we're not doing a fan
vote on my statistics thing i'm dropping
it i'm giving you the wins the best of
wins but let me just can i also just
finish a point that i'm agreeing with
you yes
i said it in the past i think the margin
of victory is
an important number and when you're
looking at the entire season and our
records i do think it is important here
however and and and i'm not just saying
because it could switch there's plenty
of show left oh yeah so i'm not just
arguing record because i have two wins
on you that could the tides can change
your real fast you've got three wins on
me but if you don't count chris's i only
have two okay right so
and and that could flip so i'm not just
arguing because i'm in the lead because
they it could hurt me if if i
if you know what i mean if i harp on
record and you take the record then i'm
just like sure i think that the
statistical number is important except
that i don't think that there's a proper
tiebreaker
because if your margin of victory is is
better is more then your average is
going to be higher those two are
directly connected so they're not a
different statistic they're just
proving the same statistic twice because
it's it's common knowledge if your
percentage spreads are higher your
number's higher i agree average is going
to be higher i agree with you that's not
that third column is not a deciding
factor i agree with you i don't mind
putting stock into some of the
percentages but then we need a tie
breaker i will say i agree with you that
the way though that we build match-ups a
lot of times we throw zero caution to
the wind and we don't care sometimes we
we even know that we're taking a big
underdog
we're taking it for the entertainment
value of the argument and to stand by a
food that we really love but we know
we're taking a big shot now
we agreed to do that so if we're
counting percentages i and we would be
more hesitant to to will nil
just pick an opponent when we know
they're going to get slower listen
because that's a statistic
that's absolutely a fair point but that
with that said i have taken
way more guaranteed losers possibly
way more well it's not way more joe i
only have two wins up more than you but
you but but i'm saying like you've said
to me far more on occasion than i've
ever said to you you're that's a death
sentence which is my opinion and i have
said but and i said i don't care i'll do
it i'm only up by two wins out of 30.
okay that's fair that's fair let me just
say this 26 30 36 episodes i'm only up
by two i agree with you a bigger margin
i agree with you
that we the the win of the season either
has to be just the number of wins or the
number of wins and percentage points
with a decent tiebreaker that we haven't
thought of yet i agree with you fans
we're up we're all ears whatever you
would what could be that tiebreaker
maybe we'll do it that way if we can
find a decent tiebreaker okay there's
that number one number two
what i was saying about chris subbing
for you and you getting that win
it's not the same i know it's a
throwaway joke but it's not the same as
saying well i had to sit the game out
and they the team still played it's a
wrestling match it's you versus me and
if you're not there to go for the belt
you don't get the belt because that
match-up never would have been the same
as my point i know but i agree all right
i'm over it i said i i i could see your
point oh okay the the the thing with me
like if i was on the bench and my team
wanted to get the ring that was just a
little fun i was having i i don't really
wasn't fun
no i no i get it i get it i'm just
saying i'm not making us i'm not i'm not
dying on that hill i was just more of a
throw i am making my other points though
which i think are valid i'm agreeing to
your other points but i also don't think
you should get the chris win because
that matchup never would have taken
place so he's just 1-0 in his own league
i think if one of us can't be here it's
just it's just a nice episode for the
fans to enjoy the show i don't even
disagree yes all right all right all
right so we're all in shape page
everything's nice yeah everything's nice
did you take beer or wine butcher box
butcher box butcher box i love butcher
box the amount of meat that i have in my
home right now is more meat than i've
ever had in my life yes and it's all
thanks to butcher box i know i love
these guys and thanks to homeless pimp
we've got more muscle in the house than
we've ever had before that's exactly
right yes but i love butcher box for the
same reason man they're bringing it
cheap affordable quality grass-fed
organic meat free range all of it fresh
wild
caught
right to your door
it's so true though it really is true
like i don't have to go to the
supermarket and also they pick out like
the best stuff it's all good quality
stuff and then they give me the range in
one shot i open that b box babe i load
up my fridge and my freezer and then i
have what equates to a restaurant menus
i'm a b-boy in my bee box stance that's
right okay okay
let me [ __ ] let me eat my let me eat
in my pants we're talking nine to 11
pounds of meat in each box it's pra it's
packed fresh it's shipped frozen it's
vacuum sealed it lasts a long time but
which is even better you ever come to my
house and ring the bell you're hungry
you tell me show me your 11 pounds of
meat i'll bring you right to it i'll
always have it here ready for you what
do you want when you come here you want
alaskan wild caught salmon done
so check this out
butcher box making it even better now
they're giving members two free lobster
tails and two free ribeyes in your first
box
these are two high-end date dinners
you're getting right out of the gate in
the first box you know what i drink with
that some nice wine
yeah all right all right you could share
a high quality surf and turf meal with
your friends or enjoy it by yourself go
to butcherbox.com
taste buds you're going to get two five
ounce lobster tails and two 10 ounce
ribeyes for free in your first box
that's butcherbox.com
taste buds and get those free lobster
tails and rib eyes when you sign up for
your new membership at butcherbox.com
taste buds
i actually have fun ordering it too like
no i do you just you just log on you
choose the frequency that you want it
you choose the box you want because they
curate like four different boxes that
have different options or you can make a
custom box that lets you choose like
your favorite stuff um they ship your
order it's frozen at the peak freshest
which you said eco-friendly 100
recyclable box they're thinking of like
all the angles if there's any reason
you'd be like i don't like to do that
but they took care of it i love angles
and they're hitting them if you enjoy
quality meat delivered to your door and
more time for amazing meals together
butcher boxes for you
folks we all shop online
i can't stop and when i say i can't stop
i mean i won't stop i will shop till i
drop that's okay i'm buying video games
i'm buying clothes i'm buying
collectibles i'm buying action figures
even though i'm 43 years old i don't
care i'm buying on paper you do not
sound like the person that you look like
yes but i agree with you and i'm also
that person and i love a discount when
i'm buying these things pieces of
shipping costs things cost extra money
all these things i want a coupon and who
brings me that coupon
honey just like honey that's what mariah
carey sings yes it is honey saves you
money that's the bottom line every
single time i order online i don't go to
the stores anymore i don't i just can't
do it and so i shop exclusively online
and that's listen if i can get into a
brick and mortar mom and pop i'll do it
i'll take you a step further i love a
mom and pop i love it i'll go to a mom
and pop me too i still go to a mom and
pop but i can't stop shop till i drop so
when i get home from the mom and pop i'm
shopping again and that's where honey's
helping me out by giving me these it's
it's
showing you coupon codes that it's just
they're popping up as you're checking
out it's a free browser extension as
you're checking out honey is popping up
and saying here are coupon codes for you
to get some bucks knocked off of this
order no joke i use it i sometimes i say
like five bucks but this this times i
see like 30 dollars
and every time i go to a checkout on an
online order and you see that that
discount code i'm always like what and i
always go open another window in my
browser and i go hunting for the code
because if they're giving you the space
it probably has a code yeah i would say
i failed like 80 of the time when this
product came across our thing that you
could just install honey yeah and then
they'll do it for you yeah it spoke to
me like nearly no other product we have
ever has and
and what i like about it is it's legit
because it doesn't pop up on every
single website you go to
it pops up on a lot of them but you know
when it's popping up it's on and that's
what it's exciting about i say like 10
bucks on flip flops yeah yeah it's
really fun 17 million members have saved
over 2
billion dollars you could go do a space
you could be the next spacex with that
money that we all save together so
joinhoney.com
taste buds it's totally free and install
you install it in a few seconds that's
it it's free you install it in a few
seconds if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out on
free savings by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
taste buds get honey for free at join
honey.com tastebuds that's joinhoney.com
taste buds
uh beer
all right
that means i'm
i'm in a good mood today
[Laughter]
what
you spent the last one hour complaining
and yelling i did not were we both
complaining and yelling you were both
complaining thank you pip thank you
thank you
i can count on pimp once in a while
somebody has my back around here
sometimes pimpenzie
i never heard that that's great
that's good
uh
okay oh and i by the way i said it on
hey babe too
said what i said i sat it on hey babe
too oh you sat in on
yes i sit in on hey babe and that those
have come out yeah so they were two
weeks ago you know and
my sitting on hey babe doesn't lead to
you eating a tarantula okay so so sorry
if i'm a little
a stickler with some of the rules
did we bring up tarantula to eat a
tarantula i was just pitching it because
we brought it up on hey babe about how
much would it take to eat a tarantula
but i don't think i could eat tarantulas
i said i would do it i said i would do
it i believe i said on air i would do it
oh no
by the way
just real quick another update real
quick because they'll see this before
they see the next hey babe uh
tattoo artists reached out to me
has offered his services
and said he will gladly tattoo the
verrazano bridge on chris and the hoagie
on me
for a very nominal fee
[Laughter]
can he can he tattoo anywhere
or her uh he
where should we film that that's gonna
be funny that's pete i'm sorry you're
getting a tattoo of a hoagie and he's
getting a tattoo of the breeze he
doesn't watch the shows when he's not on
them
i don't have the time to watch i i tried
to watch though
i tried to watch well i didn't see the
other one yet it it it's releases in a
day or two no no
oh yeah oh because you're but i watched
we're recording this before
a really nice chunk of your eyes so on
on on taste buds i challenged chris that
if he got a tattoo of the verrazano
bridge i would pay for it
but he had to get it and he was like can
i pick where it goes you can pick where
it goes but that's be somewhere visible
it can't just be you can't like get it
on your hip or something it's got to be
some place visible and he was like okay
i'll get it someplace physically i
promise but i will get it
but did he want to do that i forget how
we got onto it obviously and then on hey
babe i said i would absolutely get a
tattoo of a hoagie on me
that's how much i love hoagies and chris
was like i will pay for that if you get
it and i said i'll [ __ ] get it dude
put your money where your mouth is
because i will get it so we we we
promised each other we will both get
those tattoos if the other guy pays for
the other guy and then
i have had uh the
very kind tattoo artist reached out to
me and said i will happily do the
tattoos really yeah well he said he'll
happily do the verrazano because he
hasn't seen the hoagie one yet but i'm
sure he'll do that too i would look at
his body at work first i would also love
just to add to it maybe you guys get
each other's podcast tattooed on you
oh
that's hysterical i would do that
i would love to have the words hey babe
on me where would you get the hay babe
logo on you i'd get it like on my own
i'd get it where you could really see it
like ever so every bartender saw it
yeah
i might just do that anyway
why don't you get uh the verrazano
bridge but like the pillars are hoagies
you know or the like you got the two
stan like to two pillars and then the
bridge the actual suspension part of the
bridge is a hoagie with the blinds
connected because the reason
he's getting the verrazano bridge
is because he's soon to be staten island
trash
and i'm gonna get the hoagie because i'm
sandwich-slinging trash
so one thing is for certain
yeah you guys are about trash or trash
that's how we got onto it i think that's
what it was we were talking about
islands i both think that each of you is
pretty much just come back from rhode
island he was talking about going to
long island and he was talking about how
he was moving to staten island and i
said you have managed to occupy the only
three shitty islands
i go i go
i go anytime your island you think sun
and beaches i go what an awful trio of
islands you're garbage and then he goes
i'll get the i should have the verrazano
bridge tattooed on me and i said longest
suspension united states my friends i
said i will pay for it if you get it and
he said fine and then a very similar
thing happened on hey babe okay i was
talking about my hoagies and i was like
i love hoagies and he was like you
should have a hugely tattooed on your
piece of [ __ ] and i was like i would get
that
where i would get that the italian come
on really what the kind of question is
that how could you even ask
all the different ingredients in the
italian sandwich you know what i would
love salon you know what i love no joke
and it would be a serious serious tattoo
because it would be detailed i would
love one of those where it's all the
layers
like one two three four with the lines
and then it and then each one is labeled
almost like in a science book oh when
they like kind of spread it apart yeah
and they have like the like
tomatoes
awesome like like like that like this i
i gotta show you something that would be
awesome i actually once like like the
ingredients
yes of it yeah yeah like in a science
book when it's like a dissected frog or
whatever yeah like this i'm gonna show
you something by the way we're
approaching
and
like
35
the pole is crazy on this one guys okay
like i took this picture of a
deconstructed peanut butter and jelly
sandwich like that yes yeah yeah i get
it like that except i would make it look
like old old medical book text like
drawings yeah that's fun that'd be
awesome that's also good for your menus
that's cool yeah i'm getting that that's
what i'm making tattoos just tattooing i
promise it wouldn't cost more than two
hundred dollars
that's the bit make it like 10 grand
200 you might as well just look i bet
you could get that tattoo for 300 bucks
i'd pay the difference you you should
just get your menu tattooed on you
i mean
it's not it's not out of the realm of
possibility it's a posh it's a past yeah
are you still rocking the cold and the
hot men now
uh right now we're just cold but when we
move into the new spot there's going to
be some variege okay it's going to be
good joey rose's bar is opening in the
east the lower east side we're not
really officially announcing it should i
have said that no you could say we're
going to be doing it it's happening it's
happening it's coming big big
announcement coming very soon all right
all right
all right all right we got to get to
this fight beer
i
am not i have not been on board with the
the boom in the last decade plus of the
craft beer stuff i i when it comes to
beer i enjoy it i love an ice cold crisp
cheap lager that's where the buck stops
for me i think that a cold beer on a
beautiful warm day or with the right
meal or after a long day a cold beer is
just like a crack it open and ah it can
hit the spot i under i recognize
that
positivity in beer
for me
it kind of ends there okay i don't
understand the people that can drink
four six eight ten beers in a row it
dehydrates me it fills me up i get a
pounding headache i hate hops
hops can go take a walk
i hate hoppy beers i hate the whole like
oh you feel the notes of the honey and
the oat and come on it's a beer it
tastes like beer oh that's not true the
bud tastes like a bud a highlight tastes
like a bud
a pabst pretty much tastes like that's
true right
a course like tastes like a butter oh
that might taste like a bud and i don't
mean an old bud i just mean that cheap
lager that beer tasting knob lager where
there's no notes of anything that's beer
to me that's swash swilling
beer
warm beer is disgusting cold beer could
be delicious it goes down nice and
smooth it's light i'm not drinking it
because it's chocolate i'm not drinking
it because it has
apple infused in it i'm not drinking it
because you know i'm not i'm not i'm not
doing keg stands and and wearing a beer
helmet i i i resign that to college i
think beer is a young man's game oh this
is a young a young person's game digging
in you're digging your own grapes it's
about
you know college and and and keg parties
and fraternities and sororities and look
i know that beer like a really good
restaurant will have a really nice craft
beer menu i'm just saying i've never
subscribed okay so first of all i think
i think
i can appreciate it you know you got
your wheat beer and you got your yeah
yeah ales and you got your pills i get
all that but i don't need all that okay
i'm satisfied with just a crisp clean so
first
it could end right there first of all
thank god it finally ended christ
almighty i thought you're going to talk
to the end of the episode
first of all
nice betrayal of your best friend q
who's got his own beer company
it's a multi-billion dollar industry it
has nothing to do with my personal
opinion but i'm just saying that's honor
is honor and rna
it's something i believe in
you not so much but that's besides the
point even his he has great mixes and
all that stuff that's not good he has
great different let's get let's not get
sidetracked i have my own beer that's it
like a prince hurts brew it's hot pink
and non-alcoholic it exists let's not
get stuck swear to christ it's good yeah
that's not terrible let's not sidetrack
it it tasted like soap something
happened with the yeast
and it was the counts were off because
they did it on the fly we have a great
laugh about it because it's so funny it
was a limited run and he did it and then
there was like something happened with
the yeast and so when i went to taste
mine i had one that was affected by the
too long of the yeast and it just tasted
like like not really beer but it isn't
beer it's a non-alcoholic beverage so
anyway shout out prince herbert shout
out r h beer company
that has no bearing on one he just
figures out a way to talk even longer
it's really a gift you have
to just talk and talk and talk
and talk and talk show it's like the
gymnastics oh my god
all right so here's the thing sal first
of all almost everything you said was
wrong a butt is not a butt is not a butt
is not a bud heineken tastes
extraordinarily different from budweiser
mentioned heineken yes you did you said
yes you did you said a heineken tastes
like a bud no i didn't that's pimp
please i think you said a miller right
no he also said miller he named like
eight beers the first one he said was
heineken name the monetary wager that
you would like to place this second
i will get the money this second and he
can rewind this second and i will take
your money right now 20 bucks
i did not say heineken i'll tell you
what i said i said miller high life i
said pabst i said coors i said uh you
said heineken no i didn't yes she did i
didn't i said rolling rock you said no
you didn't say rolling rock you said
heineken i would love nothing pimp is
there a way
to settle this right now
um it's just going to take too long
we'll announce the winner in the next
episode can i make my argument
can without you speaking can we do that
for the next episode will you be able to
listen yeah we can can i make my
argument without you 20
yes
pimp
you take my winnings buddy i'm giving
you my winnings i'm gonna buy your beer
yeah
you're gonna lose i just it's just what
are you done i gotta make my argument
we're 48 minutes into this thing the
thing is i'm not done and they get more
bang for their buck then they don't pay
for this broadcast and they still
complain okay i know i know
no i all i'm saying stop talking
i have to do my argument shut up all i'm
saying no i'm not there is no home
saying i just here's the point really
quickly no no here's the point no no no
no no no no no no no no no i promise no
no no no
i just want to
make this known that this is the perfect
quintessential example for our listeners
and our viewers when joe says something
with the utmost authority and confidence
and it is not true just look at that
this is the perfect said that i said
heineken and when we go back to the
first one
burned into my head and this is the
perfect example for all of our listeners
how sal says something and then has no
recollection of it and then says he
never said it which is also a running
gag on this show i can't okay so anyway
my argument is this you are wrong okay a
butt is not a bud is not a bud every
beer you named whether it was heineken
or not pabst uh miller high life bud bud
light they all have vastly different
flavors it's why i re it's why i love a
miller high life and hate a budweiser
it's why i will not drink amstel light
at a bar it is why i will uh only drink
bud light but won't drink regular bud
it is why i like coors light versus
regular cord these beers all have very
very different flavors and it's also why
when i go to a bar and i say for
instance do you have miller high life
it's my favorite beer i love it and they
go we don't but you know what we do have
we have stella and that's
similar no it's not similar it tastes
extraordinarily different so what i'm
getting at is
beer has very different flavors that's
to respond to the first part of your
point the second part is you said it's a
young man's game
what
beer watch
beer is a young person
i'm not done i'm not done i'm not done
hold on uh you look
you're looking good lately babe it's but
thank you uh you know you too is it due
to the fitbot app it's no secret that
both of us have a hard time with
exercise right don't lump me into you
speaking i don't have a hard time with
exercise you know why was previous to
fitbot i didn't exercise fitbot makes it
a lot easier because i don't know how to
work out and not every workout is the
same person and i don't know what i'm
doing and now i have a fitbot a personal
app that i look up it tells me
there's all different workouts tailored
to what you might want to do the
repetition of exercise is what drives me
nuts you know what i mean yes the rep
the same thing over and over i always
find myself going on youtube to try to
find new videos muscle confused yeah my
dumbbell things and i'm always looking
for new vr apps and things like this
that i can do cardio stuff too fitpod's
great because it's an app that's just
going to give you the chance to find
diverse exercises uh and routines that
fit your equipment goals and your needs
this is a personalized tailored workout
basically and that's kind of what we're
all looking for because that's what's
going to keep us in the mix right they
like to say that nobody's perfect but we
could always be striving for better i
agree with that i like that the app
adapts to you like as you're going it's
like it's almost like having a personal
trainer without the fees of a personal
trainer because the more progress you
make they adapt the workouts to reflect
that i agree i agree and that's what has
always
made me fall off with personal trainers
after a while i go man i can't keep
spending this money every month it's too
much money then you miss some sessions
and you lose money or whatever it is
and let's be honest also perfectionism
perfection whatever it's an illusion
come on guys unless you're just in
silver it's an illusion we're just
trying to get better we're not trying to
get perfect so whether you're exercising
three days a week or twice a day or
every workout
so whether you're exercising three days
a week or twice a day whatever it is
every workout is scientifically proven
with the fitbot app to be better than
the last
pick up the pace on your fitness journey
with fitbot today and your future self
will thank you to our listeners i mean
there's really a lot of times we do
these ads there's nothing to lose i mean
if you're thinking of going to the gym
but you don't have a gym membership if
you can't get out because you've been in
the house because of quarantine if you
can't afford a trainer if you just want
some type of motivation why not try it
out get 25 percent off your membership
at fitbo dot me
slash taste buds by the way it's only 10
bucks a month this thing 9.99 a month
and you're getting 25 off of that or 60
bucks for the year if you want to blow
it out the egg that's 25 off at
fitbot.me
taste buds
babe i love cuts
did you get your cuts in the mail i got
my cuts in the mail i have cuts is a
clothing company that has a line of
t-shirts hoodies sweatshirts everything
you're gonna get polos
and they are
basically the whole idea is that
they are clothing for every occasion so
you could dress them up or down and i if
you know clothing and you know fashion
you're the most and i'm this is me
talking
you know that the most the most
the most important thing is to have
versatility i agree and to have your
basics and to be able to layer and to be
able to dress up and dress up couldn't
agree more those are the hallmarks those
are the big the foundation of a good
wardrobe yeah and cuts is here to help
with that from their signature buttery
soft pyca that's pronounced pica yeah
tea
uh to their pro tri blendees to their
cozy hyperloop french terry fabric
hoodies cuts elevates clothing staples
with cutting edge fabric technology gq
magazine that's gentlemen's quarterly uh
called the classic pica pro tri-blend
tea the only shirt worth wearing that's
my praise uh each piece is crafted with
custom engineered fabric and a
comfortable fit without compromising on
timeless universally flattering styles i
love a timeless dog because i've been an
old man since i was 10. jean's in a tea
babe jean's in a tee
you know no i feel like if you like me
when you're ready to go to get a whole
bunch of like new like t-shirts and
stuff i never know like
who to go to or where to choose every
brand like has their own like different
levels you want to try using i want to
find one that works and just go give it
it's just soft it's good it's quality
and you dress it up and it's like it
takes all the guesswork out so anyway go
to cutclothing.com
tastebuds for 15 off
and access to anniversary events all
month long that's cutsclothing.com
tastebuds for 15
off
and access to anniversary what do we
mean by anniversary events this mark
months cuts fifth anniversary they're
doing a bid with two collection drops a
product launch and a week-long special
event join the celebration get 15 off
site-wide no matter what you choose just
go to cutsclothing.com
how many old men do you see sitting on
porch let me
shut your mouth
[Laughter]
you have a way of taking what i said and
then arguing against you a different
thing than i said no no you said beer is
a young man's game no no i'll go back to
you
what i was saying no no no no you said
for me you should i don't like bills and
whistle beers
i understand
but then you also said beerus you also
said beer is a young man's game because
you get two full from it and you get
this and that's for young that's not why
i just think that college kids they you
said it
you said it
yeah and old man's college drink is what
i mean an old man
every old man in the country drinks beer
on his front porch and uh i go into a
bar i know what i always see in a bar
pimp you know what i always see when i
go into a dive bar is six men in their
60s drinking a fine uh merlot no you see
guys with beers
is a drink for all ages it is not an old
man's it is not a young man's game
drinks
no it's but it's but that's like saying
vodka's a college drink because because
kids in college drink absolute or uh
tequila is a college drink because the
kids shoe cuervo it's a it's a bad
argument sal you made a bad argument and
i'm now i'm right now
i'm just thinking i'm just saying
something i believe i believe that beer
is promising in college
is that is that true or false joe what
being predominant is prominent in
college
prominent in college it doesn't mean
it's a young man's thing is beer
promised at college prominence in many
places college parties is one of them no
one else is prominent at college parties
whiskey because people do shots so is
goldschlager so is jagermeister
there's a million things prominent at
college
but you could attach you could very
simply attach beer to college life could
you not you could also simply attach it
to army life you could also simply
attach it to to cowboy life this is what
it's like talking to somebody i mean
it's just you can't just admit this
isn't even a sticking point i'm not even
making a point of contention here people
just agree that beer is a college drink
i'm saying beer is a universal drink
sure i know it's it's not universal
which is what you said yes it is your
tongue and everything got messed up
that way because i was saying you're a
chill that's what i was saying
now so here and then lastly
about the flavors and the infusions and
all these things i agree with you i'm
not a huge fan of an infused flavor of
beer whatever but here's what i like
about beer over wine
it does go with a meal just like wine
does as you said
but here's what i like about beer over
wine
you did you said beer goes with a nice
meal sometimes oh i think you said i
said that about wine no and i'm saying
wine goes wonderfully with a meal
they these are the two liquors that are
alcohols that go with a meal in my
opinion correct
maybe a martini once in a while
depending on yeah i mean a beer goes
with bar fare sure
oh a beer with oysters a beer with
seafood
a beer sometimes with a steak
beer with pizza all those meals a beer
with pizza
um anyway the point is this what i
appreciate about beer over wine and i do
like wine
is that when somebody says to you
this is
uh
to this extent hoppy
to this extent infused with blueberry
to this extent the amount of alcohol and
it costs this much
you have a way better shot with beer
in getting what you just paid for
flavor-wise and also
money-wise the problem with wine is this
any hack can pour grape juice into a
bottle and tell you
that it's
it's a limited edition that it's rare
because it came from this region that
it's this and that and charge you 20
times what it's worth and you will never
know if that's the case or not because
wine always comes back to the same place
and every
what are they called
uh small s
smalliers what are they called
something yeah every seminar that i know
has always told me the same thing it's
about your taste it's about what you
like it's about you it doesn't matter if
it's if it's agreed yellowtail or if
it's this but that's a problem for me
because i know if a guy is selling me a
20 bottle of beer there's a reason it's
20
there's a reason it costs that and most
the time when i've rolled those dice
i've gotten something where i went [ __ ]
that's a 20 beer with wine
i like wine man you bring me the 75
glass or the 25 glass or the five dollar
glass i can almost never
so why tell a drastic difference just
spend the five bucks and enjoy your wine
then why isn't that a plus it's not a
plus but i think it because i think it
is a i think it's an almost impossibly
uh um
it's an almost impossibly
qualifiable beverage
because of that
because of that when there's so much
room for personal preference but i've
had a i've had a beer at a bar where
someone cracks it up and hands me a
tornado beer is a delirium or something
and i drink and i'm like i hate this
it's disgusting you can hate it that's
what that's you're making the same point
i made about beer no no i need a two
dollar beer to keep me happy that's it i
don't conversely how i don't like all
the bells and whistles and flavor
profiles and beer i don't mind it in
wine because i only i'm just telling you
my personal preference is i like that
basic crisp cheap lager flavor and
that's it that's how i like i don't need
notes in my beer with wine i like that i
could have a cab or something from one
year or one vineyard or one company that
has different notes and flavors than the
other one and i like that it's just not
all the same i mean same goes with beer
but i mean i celebrate that in wine
personally i think i've i wouldn't have
had the same probably i wouldn't have
taken wine
maybe 10 years ago but
wine right now has opened up to me
in ways that beer could never i just
can't picture drinking a beer
with with every meal or beers all the
time you know but a lot of people can
sure but i'm arguing for wine and i'm
telling you why i'm choosing wine right
you picture drinking wine with every
meal
not every single meal but
i could have wine with pizza with pasta
at a fancy restaurant with oysters with
seafood with a steak i mean wine is
great it's like you can
consume it slowly and enjoy it i feel
like you can just enjoy it a little bit
more i i just feel like
it has more
places where it's applicable i uh at the
end of the night i mean i guess some
people come home crack open a beer when
they want to relax some people come home
and crack coconut beer what i'm saying
is i do the same thing with the wine
like anything a beer can do like wine i
have a i open a bottle of wine sit down
with my dinner or if i'm watching a
television show and i have a nice glass
of wine i think i think wine is more
it's just i don't know it's just more
sophisticated i would think no one could
argue i mean it just no i a lot of
people would argue that a lot of people
especially especially beer reps when you
go into a craft beer uh distillery or
sorry brewery when you go into a real
beer spot okay
a place that really specializes it and
you see 80 literally 85 taps
of specialty beers and craft beers i i
would think any one of them would take
big issue with you and saying that beer
is not as suff as most of those people
that go to that place that has 85 taps
and i've been there are a little bit of
like tools
wow
there's there's a wow does it all right
commands
third episode you've put the working man
into the tool i have drink rolling rock
till i die
working all i'm saying is there's a venn
diagram of you know that guy
have you seen you know that have you
seen that you've seen i think you should
leave right see the first season where
tim hydeker plays that guy when they're
playing charades and he all he does is
you think that's a craft beer that's a
wine guy only a thousand people she
harps on is like oh like the jazz jazz
guys that's a wonderful record
collection and he's like he's a bit of a
boner yeah yeah i think that that's a
wine guys if there's a venn diagram i
think that that guy
he's a he's a craft beer guy no that's a
wine guy so i used to run a bar and i
used to uh have a craft beer night where
companies would come and give out free
samples and talk about the taste it was
really cool but there was a nice slice
of the people that came to that that
were real hard-ons
that just were like
and you think you're gonna find you
think you're gonna rub elbows with andy
cap and a wine tasting
no but think about how people collect
wine like when you go to somewhere yeah
that's not pretentious you're obnoxious
when a guy buys a like buys a house with
a special basement in it just for his
wine that's what i mean what i mean is
that that's that's i mean wine is wine
is collected like in a way that beer is
not why
i think wine has more to offer in that
respect well you can't beard you can't
keep beer as long as wine first of all
sure okay and also but also too but you
don't go to someone's house and they
have that they don't go
i have a selection actually i do also
they don't they aren't like i have a
selection of 20 beers downstairs but
also too but also to every mtv cribs
i've ever seen that's all that was in
the fridge but anyway but uh
also too with wine this is also why it's
such a pretentious thing you watch
documentaries about wine okay
you got these guys
literally one of the documentaries i
watched was the koch brothers
the richest brothers in all of the
country that have influenced politics
whenever else this guy's in his in his
wine cellar like showing literally
bottles of wine that thomas jefferson
owned that he paid 250 000 a piece for
and then he's like
saying like you know
i'd never drink one of them i just
that's a lot of [ __ ] with wine too
i'd never drink it i just have it so you
can see
how much better i am than poor people oh
let me let me let me let me tell you
right now that whole nonsense i don't i
don't subscribe to that either i think
it's complete [ __ ] i'm not a wine
snob same as you i could taste something
and say like it don't like it i've only
just started drinking red wine in the
last year as a matter of fact but i'm
not taking that away but that's not
how i'm pitting wine versus beer that
there are i mean i just said that like
there's hard-ons that love that craft
beer and i guess same thing goes for
wine so i'm not really but i'm just
saying for me as far as like how i
consume wine the rate at which i do it
the circumstances in which i have it i
just if i had to eliminate one from my
life at this point i would be
eliminating beer and keeping wine wine
serves me more in my lifestyle right now
than beer does i also say this which is
a thing we often discuss on this program
uh program yeah a bad beer is 10
000 times better than a bad wine
bad wine is brutal bad beer is you if
you've got a natty ice
it would not be your favorite thing in
the world but you could get that down
you'd be like yeah all right i don't
want another one but that was fine if
you get like a bad you go to a bar turn
do you mean no no no no no no i don't
mean it's turned i mean that's terrible
okay that's poorly made or you don't
mean it's correct like when you go to a
bar when you go to a bar that says wine
red or white yeah that's what i'm
talking about yeah yeah yeah sure it is
it is it's like a bad white wine tastes
like vinaigrette dressing it tastes like
you're drinking salad dressing if you
had to eliminate one of those two
beverages from your life from now on you
would eliminate wine and you would keep
beer
based on what i just said absolutely
really i just don't see myself i can't
go being able to consume beer at a level
where i would keep it over wine you look
at it like this think about the options
with wine you could do a spritzer throw
a little club soda in that so some ice
some people like to drink their red wine
with ice yeah some people what about
sangria it's wine
i hate it i really hate it i hate it
really and you wanted to i hate it on a
beautiful day you know i love it
nice diced i hate it fruit you want me
to shut down the hole why you keep beer
over wine argument in one fell swoop
do it finally i'll tell you why
shot and a beer buddy you're not giving
that up on a friday night you're hitting
the town you're telling me you want to
bar hop with me and drink wine the whole
time i'm saying that i would have to do
some
really soul search in there because i
know a shot and a beer is a thing but i
could also just take a shot and if you
think i can't do a wine in a shot
watch me watch me spread my wings and
flowers disgusting i will do a shot of
whatever and then i will sip on wine
uh this one
you had something up that you you really
wanted me to hit there that way
wine comes cheap it's a known fact you
can buy good beer much cheaper than the
best of wines you can however buy
quality wine at a lower price than
quality beer
it thus turns out wine is cheaper than
beer since people rarely go out for the
best of the two most usually they
purchase a reasonably priced drink when
in need of relaxation you are likely to
find a higher number of quality cheap
wine brands in your local store than you
think of i i mean i wouldn't disagree
with that but you know that's sort of an
unfair point for this reason everybody
and their french uncle has a vineyard
now
i mean you know i can't go
is that a is that i don't know i just
sounded right
i don't know
that on merch yes
what a statement to use in an argument
as an anchor to your argument everybody
with a french uncle has i mean dude
you'll go to the you'll go to the you'll
go to a wine shop right yeah the wine
shop or even you'll even just go to a
liquor store that also carries wine
and from week to week
you will not see many of the same brands
on the shelf you will go to you know
many times they're going to parties and
met people that have their own wine it
happens constantly really not constantly
but it's happened it's happened way more
than i've met people that people make
their own beer people make their own
wine at home but q is the only guy i
know that has an official this is my own
brand of beer sure i know i've met
several people over the years apart as
they're like no i have wine it's a store
you could buy it it's called this really
yeah because they collaborate with five
other rich men and they they well that's
because can i just talk about the
essence and the uh the
the the the the culture of of wine at
least
wine is you crack open a bottle it's
very communal
you know like you split a bottle of wine
over dinner cool if i want to drink a
bottle of wine and four glasses it's
like the perfect amount you get the four
glasses you float it up you go to bed
whatever you want drinking a bottle of
wine is not unheard of you know see i
feel that but also like you crack open a
wine
and everyone's sharing the wine you know
jesus jesus you go to church
they give you the body of christ the
blood of christ the blood of christ is
why it's funny that's funny that you
mentioned jesus because last night i
just i rewatched last temptation for
christ
is this a call for help no i remember
you just were home alone and you threw
on the last time
i wanted to watch jesus have s
wait you're you're home alone let's do a
profile on this boy right here let's do
a profile on this man right here he's
home alone and he throws on last
temptation of christ did you watch it in
full
frame oh my god
heavy dessert during it
during torture christ
ate this earth touring it now i say the
dessert jim cavill
no that's a passion of the christ oh
what am i thinking you're thinking of
the scorsese movie last statistic of
christ where he comes off the cross and
then he lives a man's life that's why i
said i wanted to watch jesus have s he
has he has sex in the third eye oh i'm
thinking of the people because he
becomes no i thought passion in the
question
he doesn't have sex and passion of
christ i don't make it to
i don't know if i watched it it's a
jesus doesn't have sex in anything guys
just a heads up except for the last
temptation of christ right which is why
people
well i just threatened scorsese with his
life
passion the christ in so long and i
wasn't gonna con
i wasn't gonna i wasn't gonna contest
you listen here's the thing i thought
that he was at home
why is jesus having sex
listen i got news for you guys
against the book last temptation is no
walk in the park either all right it's
just
gonna pick me up why are you watching
religious drama i don't know
it's just a scorsese movie you're just
drinking beer at the beer i just hadn't
seen it in a while and i was like you
know what's on i want to watch it all
right so i watched it why is he upset
with the blood of christ is my power you
ask a question though real quick why is
there because it's a fictional account
that what if he did not take the wrath
of the path of saving the world and just
became a normal man oh last temptation
he gets tempted at the end of his life
like jesus you could be a normal man
then he sees what it would be like and
they show it oh wow i always
i always
he refutes it at the end and stays jesus
and and saves the world all right all
right yeah well my my point though it is
sorry
no but but my point is you know wine
i had a point yeah is the drink of
christ i know that but that wasn't my
that wasn't my actual point before that
you said sharing and everything and i
have a counterpoint to your sharing
thing with the wine do you ever walk
summertime backyard barbecue it's sunny
everybody's in their shorts or their
jorts as i do it okay everybody's having
a great time the grill's going you're
walking up the driveway you smell the
grill the charcoal smoke your boys are
in there where are you at dude i'm i had
to make a stop and you walk in
hold in that 12-pack of miller high-life
bottles and you put it right down
between you and your fourth boys and you
pull it open not a college truck though
i do this 43 i do
let me paint the picture about wine i
have a great i'm just saying there's a
way to share awesome he's having
everybody over for a dinner party it's
gonna be the food's gonna be out of
control everyone threw on a nice college
shirt maybe there's a there's a whole
there's good music playing
there's a lot of good company we sit
down steaks are being served and someone
pops open that cork and i hear and the
bottle of red wine is being poured oh
man that just pursed my lips i can't
wait to taste that red wine before my
steak had a beautiful dinner party with
adult people
you know what i mean like he's like i
kick open the door with a 12 pack my
boys are there that's like the college
life and i'm like hey i got invited to a
dinner party it's a lot of great guys
and gals there's going to be some good
conversations
i love candlesticks try to portray
yourself to this audience as someone
with class and dignity parties i love
when you try to do this so i come here
for dinner i have only stood in circles
with you getting [ __ ] fixed i have never
sat at a decent table with me
and then drake rides
all right let's go to the phones pimp
we're at an hour let's see what the
comments say here
i saw by the way i accidentally saw a
comment early and i was like
i hope we find it again i almost said
put a pin in it all right it was my i
can't imagine somebody's gonna beat it
it was hard not to laugh when i went to
the phones last week uh and uh no one
gave you [ __ ] nobody gave me well i'll
go to the phones in an hour that's no
problem it's when you like to rush to
the phones our show's supposed to be 30
minutes long i understand yeah
okay what do we got beer is for
disrespectful frat boys wine is for men
very good i'm a beer guy but straight up
on taste alone wine is so much better
that's another thing if you just stop
for one moment beer literally tastes
like cat okay oh wait there's my
favorite comment after this one okay
beer literally tastes like cat piss only
baddies drink wine here's this one's my
favorite one so far what am i a 32 year
old mom updating her pinterest catalog
beer 100
questions no you don't like that i don't
love it i loved it let me ask you a
question let's not let's not negate a
huge factor that beer really doesn't
taste good yes it does i've learned to
like it i think it tastes good news i
learned to like wine too buddy i was at
a a barbecue my parents my mom threw a
barbecue in the yard and we had people
always like a pool party type thing and
i was like
16 something like that whatever i mean i
might have tasted it one other time but
anyway i thought i was like cool so i
cracked open i remember at a rolling
rock and my mom's like don't do that i'm
like why i'm home it's cool ma like i
think i was 17 and i'm like what's the
big deal and my and like i i guess i was
testing it and my mom was like you you
shouldn't really drink that and i'm like
ah it's no big deal mom it's one beer
i'm home like what's the big deal and i
and i had never really had beer before
and i tasted it and
my whole body shivered and recoiled and
discussed because it's an acquired taste
for sure and so is wine i drank it you
know what i i went into the bathroom
i dumped the rolling rock and then i
walked out and i and i just kept talking
because i didn't want people to after i
made the whole hullabaloo that i wanted
to it's no big deal i could drink i'm
17. and then i thought it was so gross i
didn't want it i dumped it in the sink
then came out and i i perpetrated that i
that i actually drank the beer i mean i
don't know what to tell you that at 17
you couldn't stomach a beer but uh but
i'm just saying you know but but if we
really i don't know but i i had a
different i had a different experience
that the first time it tasted you said
this is delicious first
i was six years old i loved it i would
beg my dad for a ship every time he had
one got it every time i no no don't
dismiss it that's true every time my dad
drank a beer i'd beg him for a sip i
loved the taste of it okay why in the
minority why are you being right i don't
think so people
so is wine so is when you see wine you
think it's gonna taste like grape juice
and it and you're like whoa it burns
like acid it tastes nothing like it wine
is an acquired taste what alcohol is not
an acquired taste i think beer is more
acquired taste than water you're nuts
dude why
then i guess college kids should all be
drinking wine then if that's their first
drink so it so easily goes down right
why aren't they all drinking as a
society we could all admit we acquire
the taste of beer and love it now but
just you look good
taste test face value beer is a weird
tasting so is wine all alcohol is more
so beer no more so wine and you proved
it with your college kids point anyway
let's go back to the phones
wine is classier and taste slightly
better and i've gotten drunk way more
easily on wine than beer so yeah i got
to go with wine i like this next one
beer tastes like carbonated bread water
wine tastes like somebody pissed in
grape juice they both suck but i guess
i'll vote beer
uh it'll never cease to amaze me that my
fellow men would prefer to guzzle down a
bottle of stale iron kid's bread in
liquid form
uh vikings drank beer dainty
vikings shrek beer dainty frenchman
drank wine would you rather drink the
drink of a warrior or a snob beer all
day that that's our winner so far so far
i don't drink much for sure what's this
i don't drink much but for sure wine
beer tastes like a life of regrets do
you want to read some of these sure of
wine if wine wins this i will lay on a
bed of salt and paper cuts on my nipples
for the patreon i couldn't be more
confident in my old pal beer okay here's
for the people one is for people who
think they are fancy while scarfing down
breadsticks at olive garden or christy
comedy aka christine pinot noir i'd
rather drink piston beer then again i
can't tell the goddamn difference
that's a good that's a good one wine
people learn about the different types
of wine and then act like they aren't
alcoholics because it came with an
education
people drink wine because they think
they look high class give me that low
class beer and let me have fun as
someone who works at a wine shop i feel
i have an obligation to say wine but
even if i didn't have that job beer
still tastes like piss so who's the real
winner
okay i'm gonna go with wine on this one
because i haven't found a beer i like
yet okay
too much wine gives me a migraine too
much beer got me pregnant three times so
i guess it's a toss up all right that's
our winner right there that's good
alicia
uh catrin
follow alicia at
a-l-i-c-a-t
7783 on twitter you're our winning tweet
thanks elish all right this is going to
be telling it's i think if i if my audi
if my twitter follower sku
skew more younger
or more male i think beer's going to win
if my twitter followers skew
more older or more female i think wine's
gonna win all right let's go
oh holy [ __ ] oh
oh you're gonna need a glass of wine
after that one buddy i
am in shock
i am in shock 66
goes to beer against wines 33.
well i'm in shock
wow
i mean at least i thought it would be
like neck and neck the whole
episode i i swear to god i thought it
was going to be a dead heat i thought it
was going to be a tie
i thought it was going to be a tie wow
me too man
when you told me you got you know what
we discussed this and you said wine is
more of a metropolitan cosmopolitan
beverage maybe then
well i think you know honestly you have
in between like you know you got the
major cities but you got in the middle
of the country they're drinking beer
over wine hey well listen you could
phrase it however you want to phrase it
here's how i'd like to phrase it beer
is america still love you buddy i love
you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds